Stop thinking and start doing.
One of my favorite stories is of Mary Kay Ash.
She was a successful entrepreneur, founder of Mary Kay cosmetics.
Her life changed when she was a young mother and her husband came back from the war and...
ran off with another woman.
And she now had to find a way to support the family, so she joined up with a direct sales company...
and was selling things door to door.
And she quickly became the #1 salesperson at the business, but she was passed over on...
opportunities for promotion because she was a woman.
She kept seeing men with less experience, less success, be promoted ahead of her.
So she said: "I'm tired of this! I'm not going to do this anymore!...
I´m going to go find another company!"
So she hooked up with a different direct sales company, she brought her experience there and, again,...
she quickly became on of the top sales people there.
And she earned a few promotions and she even got on the board of directors.
But she kept getting put down because she was a woman.
Her ideas would be ignored and the board would frequently tell her:
"Oh, Mary Kay, you're just thinking like a woman."
A comment that constantly infuriated her.
She got so frustrated and her breaking point came when one of the guys that she trained, for years at the...
business, was promoted to be her boss and paid twice her salary. And she said:
"That's it. I'm done! I can't handle these companies, I'm not being respected,...
I'm not being treated like I'm adding value, so I'm done!" And she quit.
And she went home and said: "You know what? I'm going to write a book!"
"I'm going to write a book and I'm going to talk about all the reasons why corporate America is wrong...
right now. And how women are being passed over and how this isn't right!"
"And then I'm also going to include a section on what an ideal company should look like."
"How people would be treated with respect and how business should be run."
And then the turning point came. She said: "Instead of just thinking about it, instead of just writing about it,...
"I'm going to go do it! I'm going to launch my own business that would be the ideal company to work for."
And she turned all the negative things that happened to her in her life, how she was passed over repeatedly...
and being put down for being a woman.
She took all that negative energy and turned it into something amazingly positive.
And took an idea from nothing, from scratch, just an idea, into a billion dollar plus company.
And when she was asked: "What do you think your legacy is going to be?", she said:
"I think the biggest legacy we're going to leave is a whole community of children who believe they can do anything...
in this world because they watched their mommas do it."
So stop thinking about it, stop writing about it and start doing.
Believe!
For those of you watching and liked the video, please give it a thumbs up below,...
it makes me want to do more videos for you.
Let me know what you think. Leave a comment underneath.
Ask me a question, I'll make a video response.
Click on my face to subscribe to the channel to see more videos like this.
Thank you so much! I'll see you soon.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community